Let's suppose that we have a TCP sender that's
sending packets, where the sending rate is controlled by
the window W, and it's receiving ACKs. Now at
any time if the window's W, only W unacknowledged
packets may be outstanding. So the sender's sending rate,
R, is simply the TCP window, W, divided by
the round trip time of the path. So the
rate is W over RTT. Now remember that TCP uses
additive increase, multiplicative decrease, or AIMD, congestion control.
So for every W ACKs received, we send W
plus one packets, and our TCP sawtooth will look
something like this. We'll start at a rate W
max over 2, increase the window to W max and then when we see a drop we
will apply multiplicative decrease and reduce the sender's sending
rate to W max over 2 again. So here,
right at the point of a packet drop, this represents
the maximum number of packets that can be in flight. So
again, the required buffer is the maximum number of packets
that can be in flight, or simply the height of this
TCP sawtooth. Now we know the rate is W over
RTT, and we'd like the sender to send at a common
rate, R. And if we'd like the sender to be sending
at the same rate before and after it experiences a loss,
then we know that the rate before the drop must
equal the rate after the drop. So then we can set
these two rates equal. We know that the RTT is part
transmission delay T, and part queuing delay which is the maximum
buffer size of the bottleneck link, divided by the capacity
of the bottleneck link. We also know that after reducing the
window, the queuing delay is zero. So we can replace the
term on the left with W old over 2T plus B
over C and we can replace the term on
the right with W old over 2, because the congestion
window has been reduced half divided by 2T. Simply the
propagation delay with no queuing delay. Now if we solve
this equation we find that the required buffering is simply
2T times C. Now the rule of thumb makes sense
for a single flow, but a router in a typical
backbone network has more than 20,000 flows. And it turns
out that this rule of thumb only really holds
if all of the those 20,000 flows are perfectly synchronized.
If the flows are desynchronized, then it turns out
that this router can get away, with much less buffering.